over a decade has passed since Ron
Perlman stormed the screen as everyone's
favorite half demon but is this beloved
cult series dead and buried or is there
hope for Hellboy yet Sony's 2004 movie
Hellboy may have been met with plenty of
fanfare in the comic book fan Community
but it didn't muster much excitement
from wider audiences despite being made
on a relatively modest budget for a
spring action movie Hellboy flapped at
the box office failing to even pass the
100 million dollar Mark in fact it's
actually quite remarkable that it even
got a sequel at all and it remains one
of the few box office bombs to receive a
follow-up at Hellboy 2 the Golden Army
even happened might be down to director
Guillermo del Toro's Newfound clout in
Hollywood following the Academy Award
wins for his 2006 film Pan's Labyrinth
arriving in 2008 and distributed This
Time by Universal the Golden Army may be
an even better movie than the previous
film and it performed better at the box
office too but with an 82 million dollar
budget the movie still couldn't be
considered a hit and two consecutive
lackluster performances weren't a good
sign for the franchise over the years
the cast and crew behind the Hellboy
films have had much to say about a
potential third installment in the
series unfortunately it's all been
pretty sobering and that goes especially
for Guillermo del Toro himself since the
release of the Golden Army the director
has acknowledged that no studio is
likely to give him the budget he needs
to make a third movie in 2013 he told
collider it's very unlikely it'll happen
because you need things to converge so
strongly Del Toro went on to say that
many things need to come together for
Hellboy 3 to happen when the IP's rights
the Ron perlman's schedule to Comic
Creator Mike mignola's blessing and then
he added you need 150 million dollars on
top of that given the mediocre response
at the ticket counter for the first two
films this all seems pretty unlikely
even star Ron Perlman seems to believe
that we've probably Seen the Last of his
version of the character in 2021 he told
inverse Hellboy Saga was always meant to
be a Trilogy it was a shame the audience
who had hung in with us for the first
two films was deprived of seeing that
finish because it would have been a big
beautiful finish I'll never give up on
you
[Music]
ever
like that Guillermo del Toro has long
expressed his hopes to turn the Hellboy
films into a Trilogy and according to
the director it's pretty much all he
ever really wanted it wasn't quite as
Keen as other Studios about turning
Hellboy into a full-blown franchise
however so he had subsequently figured
out a plan to end hellboy's story in the
third movie before the release of the
Golden Army he told sci-fi if there was
ever a third one I would really make
sure that we at least sign a contract
that there is no more no prequels and no
sequels nothing there is a third one we
have planned and the seeds are planted
in this film according to the director
the plot would also have seen the gun
toting bprd agent Hellboy taking on a
new breed of Nazis in the modern day he
said it's not this group of freakies
that hide in the sewers but people that
are incredibly rich in a 2016 Reddit AMA
Del Toro went into even more detail
about his dream Hellboy prequel he said
the idea for it was to have Hellboy
finally come to terms with the fact that
his Destiny his inevitable Destiny is to
become the Beast of the apocalypse and
having him and Liz face that part of his
nature he has to become the Beast of the
Apocalypse to be able to defend Humanity
but at the same time he becomes a much
darker being the first two films in the
Hellboy series boasted impressive casts
in addition to Star Ron Perlman the
movies feature Selma Blair as fire
starter Liz Sherman Doug Jones as Fish
Man Ape Sapien John herds as Professor
broom and a Supporting Cast and included
Jeffrey Tambor and Rupert Evans if there
ever is going to be a third film in the
series you can bet that at least Ron
Perlman would be back even if he is well
past retirement age in 2022 he told the
independent am I eager to do Hellboy 3
no I'm 71 years old that said it seems
he just can't bring himself to say no
Perlman continued we owe this to the
fans and we should give it to them
because it would be an epic conclusion
so Guillermo if you're reading I'm not
done pounding you to get this thing done
let me go in and say hi Pearlman isn't
the only one interested in coming back
either and it sounds like a potential
prequel would reunite much of the
original cast in 2019 Samuel Blair told
Cinema Blend that she wished she could
star in Hellboy 3 more than anything in
the world in an interview with
comicbook.com Doug Jones was also
enthusiastic about returning his Aid he
said if they were to do such a thing and
I was offered that and I was free to do
so hell yes I would be involved by the
late 2010s the lights had dimmed on the
prospects of Hellboy 3 but Hollywood
just couldn't shake the franchise's
potential so in 2019 Hellboy reboot was
released in theaters stranger things
Star David Harbor played the title role
this time around and he seemed perfectly
suited to the character a larger than
life figure with a Gruff attitude and a
unique sense of charm but any hopes for
outdoing del Toro's original films were
immediately dashed when it bombed in
theaters the woeful reviews didn't
exactly help either just barely making
back its budget 2019's Hellboy had none
of the style or substance of del Toro's
version and many felt it was a
completely unnecessary reboot that
wasted the Goodwill still from the
previous movies original Star Ron
Perlman was quick to express a complete
lack of interest in the reboot admitting
that he didn't plan on watching the
movie his old Empire it was none of my
business it would only provoke me into
whatever things I didn't need to add to
my list of grievances speaking about his
own potential return to the role hurlman
made it clear that Del Toro would have
to be sitting in the director's chair he
said without him I have no interest in
donning the makeup again if there is
anyone who has been more vocal about
Hellboy 3 than Ron Perlman it would have
to be the movie's fans despite the first
film's disappointment at the box office
it became a cult classic among sci-fi
horror and superhero movie fans which is
exactly what helped get the first sequel
made in the first place even after the
Golden Army failed to meet box office
expectations those same fans began
campaigning for a threequel to be made
online petitions have popped up
frequently over the years and while they
failed to gain enough traction to
interest any studio in a third movie it
showed that fans meant business in an
interview with red carpet news TV
Perlman said it's so deserved by the
fans who hung in there for the first two
that I really feel as though it's
essential that we make but he wasn't the
only one to acknowledge the support from
people demanding a third Hellboy movie
taking to his Twitter accounts in 2017
director Guillermo del Toro thanked the
fans for their support at the time the
fandom was reacting with a mixture of
astonishment and disappointment at the
news that Hellboy would be getting a
reboot instead of a third film but even
that project didn't stop fans from
pushing for more of del Toro's Vision
one Twitter user echoed the sentiment to
many in 2023 when they wrote bring back
Ron Perlman considering the cost
associated with producing Guillermo del
Toro's third Hellboy film and the
mediocre performances of the first two
films at the box office we already know
that Hellboy 3 probably won't happen and
it seems that there's one more big
problem standing in its way yet another
Hellboy reboot which was announced in
2023 this movie will be spearheaded by
director Brian Taylor whose most recent
comic adaptation was the 2017 series
happy titled Hellboy the Crooked Man the
second attempt to reboot the character
will put a new spin on the story taking
place in the 1950s the movie is intended
to be a period piece in which Hellboy a
fresh-faced bprd agent investigates a
coven of witches in a small Appalachian
Town Jack kessie is set to Star as
Hellboy while Yellowstone star Jeffrey
white and Riverdale star Adeline Rudolph
will also appear going back to the comic
book Roots the second reboot will also
feature a script from Hellboy Creator
Mike mignola and Christopher golden who
has spent several Hellboy novels will it
work who knows if it does though it
could Hammer the final nail into Hellboy
3's coffin The Hope may seem lost in
rounding out the original Hellboy
Trilogy one unique opportunity may allow
it to finally come to fruition today
lesser successful cult hits have been
enjoying comebacks of their own despite
floundering at the box office and some
critics have suggested that Hellboy was
ahead of its time just missing the
superhero movie boom sparked by Marvel's
MCU which kicked off the same summer as
the Golden Army some 15 years have now
passed since that second film plenty of
time for a new generation to discover
the Hellboy movies on streaming and home
video and the passion shared by Die Hard
fans is never faltered meanwhile
mid-budget horror and tongue-in-cheek
sci-fi has never been more popular and
while Ron Perlman is indeed getting up
there in years and maybe running out of
time to play Hellboy stories about older
heroes are more popular than ever in
fact the likes of Halloween ends Logan
and Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny
have proved that audiences can still
love heroes at the end of their Journey
maybe there is still hope for Hellboy
after all
foreign